SAYING, QUOTE, TO SUGGEST WE
ENCOURAGE BAD CONTENT AND DO
NOTHING IS JUST NOT TRUE.
DONIE O'SULLIVAN IS OUTFRONT ON
CAPITOL HILL TO BEGIN OUR
COVERAGE TONIGHT.
AND, DONIE, FACEBOOK JUST COMING
BACK ONLINE AFTER A VERY
TROUBLING DAY FOR THE COMPANY.
I MEAN, SIX HOURS OUT WAS
STUNNING, ON ITS OWN.
NEVER MIND, AGAINST THE BACKDROP
OF THIS INCREDIBLE MOMENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ERIN.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT POWER.
TODAY WAS A REMINDER OF
FACEBOOK'S POWER.
THAT PLATFORM, THAT COMPANY
CONTROLLING THREE OF THE WORLD'S
BIGGEST SOCIAL-MEDIA PLATFORMS.
FACEBOOK, INSTAGRAM, AND
WHATSAPP.
WE ARE LEARNING NOW THAT THE --
THE SERVICES ARE SLOWLY COMING
BACK ONLINE.
THIS WAS VERY UNUSUAL, BY THE
WAY.
FACEBOOK WAS OUT -- OUT FOR
ALMOST SIX HOURS TODAY WHICH
BASICALLY NEVER HAPPENS.
UM, WHY THAT ALL HAPPENED?
WE DON'T KNOW, YET.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE COMPANY IS
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
BUT AS ONE HEADACHE ENDS TODAY
FOR FACEBOOK, A NEW ONE BEGINS
TOMORROW HERE BEHIND ME IN
CAPITOL HILL WHEN A
WHISTLE-BLOWER WILL TESTIFY
ABOUT ALL OF THE COMPANY'S ILLS.
ABOUT THEIR CORROSIVE IMPACT ON
DEMOCRACY, AND A KEY COMPONENT
OF THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
ALLEGATIONS IS ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS THAT INSTAGRAM
AND FACEBOOK CAN HAVE ON
TEENAGERS' MENTAL HEALTH.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> IMAGINE YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON INSIDE OF FACEBOOK, AND YOU
KNOW NO ONE ON THE OUTSIDE
KNOWS.
>> Reporter: MEET FRANCES, A
37-YEAR-OLD DATA SCIENTIST FROM
IOWA.
SHE LEFT FACEBOOK IN MAY AFTER
WORKING ON THE COMPANY'S CIVIC
INTEGRITY TEAM THROUGH LAST
YEAR'S ELECTION.
THAT TEAM CHARGED WITH PROTECT
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND
REDUCING THE SPREAD OF VIRAL
MISINFORMATION AND FAKE
ACCOUNTS.
>> THEY TOLD US WE'RE DISSOLVING
CIVIC INTEGRITY.
LIKE, THEY BASICALLY SAID, OH,
GOOD, WE MADE IT THROUGH THE
ELECTION.
THERE WASN'T RIOTS.
WE CAN GET RID OF CIVIC
INTEGRITY NOW.
FAST FORWARD A COUPLE MONTHS, WE
GOT THE INSURRECTION.
AND WHEN THEY GOT RID OF CIVIC
INTEGRITY, IT WAS THE MOMENT
WHERE I WAS LIKE I DON'T TRUST
THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO
ACTUALLY INVEST WHAT NEEDS TO BE
INVESTED TO KEEP FACEBOOK FROM
BEING DANGEROUS.
>> Reporter: A FACEBOOK
EXECUTIVE RESPONDED ON TWITTER
SUNDAY NIGHT SAYING THEY DIDN'T
SHUT DOWN THE CIVIC INTEGRITY
TEAM.
INSTEAD, HE SAID THEY FOLDED IT
INTO A WIDER TEAM.
HAUGEN WALKED OUT OF FACEBOOK
WITH THOUSANDS OF COMPANY
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING THE
COMPANY'S OWN RESEARCH LIKE
THIS.
A PRESENTATION ABOUT THE DANGERS
OF INSTAGRAM FOR TEENAGERS.
WE MAKE BODY ISSUES WORSE FOR
ONE IN THREE GIRLS, READS ONE
SLIDE.
TEENS WHO STRUGGLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH SAY INSTAGRAM MAKE IT
WORSE, READS ANOTHER.
>> WHAT'S SUPERTRAGIC IS
FACEBOOK'S OWN RESEARCH SAYS AS
THESE YOUNG WOMEN BEGIN TO
CONSUME THIS EATING DISORDER
CONTENT, THEY GET MORE AND MORE
DEPR
DEPRESSED IT ACTUALLY MAKES THEM
USE THE APP MORE.
AND SO, THEY END UP IN THIS
FEEDBACK CYCLE WHERE THEY HATE
THEIR BODIES MORE AND MORE.
FACEBOOK'S OWN RESEARCH SAYS IT
IS NOT JUST THAT INSTAGRAM IS
DANGEROUS FOR INSTAGRAM, THAT IT
HARMS TEENAGERS.
IT'S THAT IT IS DISTINCTLY WORSE
THAN OTHER FORMS OF SOCIAL
MEDIA.
>> Reporter: ETERNALLY STARVED.
I HAVE TO BE THIN.
SKIN AND BONE.
ALL INSTAGRAM PAGES THE
PLATFORM'S ALGORITHM SUGGESTS AN
ACCOUNT REGISTERED TO A
13-YEAR-OLD GIRL SHOULD FOLLOW.
>> WHAT WE DID WAS TO CREATE A
13-YEAR-OLD WHO EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN WEIGHT LOSS AND
DIETING.
AND WITHIN A DAY, SHE WAS
FLOODED WITH RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ACCOUNTS CONCERNING EATING
DISORDERS AND PERSONAL INTRIGUE.
>> INSTAGRAM SAID ETERNALLY
STARVED I HAVE TO BE THIN SKIN
AND BONE, THE ACCOUNT IT HAD
PROMOTED THROUGH ITS ALGORITHM
BROKE THE COMPANY'S RULES
ENCOURAGING EATING DISORDERS BUT
THEY ONLY REMOVED THE ACCOUNTS
AFTER BEING CONTACTED BY CNN.
>> THIS EXPERIENCE SHOWS VERY
GRAPHICALLY HOW THESE CLAIMS TO
PROTECT CHILDREN OR TAKE DOWN
ACCOUNTS THAT MAY BE DANGEROUS
TO THEM ARE ABSOLUTE HOGWASH.
IN FACT, IT WAS NOT TAKEN DOWN
UNTIL CNN BROUGHT IT TO THEIR
ATTENTION.
>> Reporter: A SPOKESPERSON FOR
INSTAGRAM'S PARENT COMPANY,
FACEBOOK, SAID IT USES
TECHNOLOGY AND REPORTS FROM
USERS TO REMOVE CONTENT THAT
VIOLATES ITS RULES AND EATING
DISORDERS AS QUICKLY AS IT IS.
ADDING, THEY ARE ALWAYS WORKING
TO IMPROVE.
AND VIEWERS AFFECTED BY ISSUES
MENTIONED IN THAT REPORT CAN
CONTACT THE NATIONAL EATING
DISORDER ASSOCIATION HELP LINE.
# BUT JUST FINALLY, ERIN, JUST
TO UNDERLINE WHAT YOU SAW IN
THAT REPORT THERE.
THE SENATOR'S OFFICE SET UP AN
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT DESIGNED TO
LOOK LIKE IT WAS A 13-YEAR-OLD
GIRL AND INSTAGRAM BEGAN PUSHING
PRO-EATING DISORDER ACCOUNTS TO
THIS 13-YEAR-OLD AFTER THE
ACCOUNT SEARCHED AND FOLLOWED A
FEW ACCOUNTS THAT WERE TALKING
ABOUT ANOREXIA AND WERE
GLORIFYING EATING DISORDERS.
BUT INSTAGRAM WAS FEEDING INTO
THAT.
ERIN.
>> DONIE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S SO DISTURBING.
>>> I WANT TO GO NOW TO ANDREW.
HE IS A LAWYER REPRESENTING
FACEBOOK WHISTLE-BLOWER FRANCES
HAUGEN AND HE WORKS WITH LEGAL
NONPROFIT WHISTLE-BLOWER AID.
LOOK, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
THERE'S SO MUCH TO TALK ABOUT
HERE.
FIRST OF ALL, CAN I JUST ASK YOU
GIVEN WHAT HAPPENED, YOU KNOW,
NOW YOUR CLIENT'S SPEAKING OUT.
WE KNOW HER NAME.
SHE'S GOING TO TESTIFY.
HAVE YOU OR YOUR CLIENT HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM FACEBOOK SINCE SHE
REVEALED HER IDENTITY?
>> TO MY KNOWLEDGE, WE HAVE NOT
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM FACEBOOK,
NOT YET.
>> WOW.
SO I WANT TO READ PART OF A
STATEMENT FROM FACEBOOK IN
RESPONSE TO HER CLAIMS BECAUSE I
GUESS THAT'S ALL WE HAVE SINCE
THEY HAVEN'T REACHED OUT TO YOU.
UM, THEY SAY CBS 60 MINUTES RAN
A SEGMENT THAT USED SELECT
COMPANY MATERIALS TO TELL A
MISLEADING STORY ABOUT THE
RESEARCH WE DO TO IMPROVE OUR
PRODUCTS.
THE SEGMENT ALSO DISREGARDS THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WE MAKE
TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE ON OUR
PLATFORM.
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO TACKLE THE
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION AND
HARMFUL CONTENT.
TO SUGGEST WE ENCOURAGE BAD
CONTENT AND DO NOTHING IS JUST
NOT TRUE.
SO, WHEN YOU HEAR THAT, ANDREW,
ARE YOU CONFIDENT, IS YOUR
CLIENT CONFIDENT THAT SHE KNOWS
EVERYTHING THAT FACEBOOK IS
DOING TO KEEP THE PLATFORM SAFE?
AND THAT SHE HASN'T MISSED
ANYTHING SIGNIFICANT?
>> I THINK WE ARE VERY
CONFIDENT.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THEIR
OWN INTERNAL DOCUMENTS ESTABLISH
THEY COULD HAVE DONE MORE.
I THINK A KEY IMPORTANT ELEMENT
OF FRANCES'S COURAGE AND MAKING
THESE DISCLOSURES TO THE SCC AND
TO CONGRESS IS FACEBOOK HAS NOT
ONLY DONE THE RESEARCH TO
IDENTIFY THE PROBLEMS THAT IT
FOSTERS HERE AT HOME, AS WELL AS
ABROAD.
THEY KNOW THE MECHANISMS, THE
TOOLS IN WHICH THEY CAN TAKE TO
EFFECT POSITIVE CHANGE.
TO MITIGATE AGAINST HATE,
AGAINST VIRAL MISINFORMATION
BECAUSE ONE THING I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT FACEBOOK IS A
VEHICLE BY WHICH MISINFORMATION
SPREADS GLOBALLY.
IT HAS IMPACTED CHILDREN HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES, AND IT HAS
IMPACTED EVEN INDIVIDUALS AS FAR
AS MYANMAR WHERE THERE WAS A
GENOCIDE THAT WAS INFLUENCED BY
FACEBOOK.
>> SO, ONE SPECIFIC FACEBOOK --
UM -- CLAIM -- ONE CLAIM THEY
TAKE ISSUE WITH IS THE ONE ABOUT
THE INSTAGRAM IMPACT ON TEEN
GIRLS.
YOU REFER TO CHILDREN AND I KNOW
YOU JUST HEARD, OBVIOUSLY, THE
REPORT THAT TALKS ABOUT THAT.
AND THE COMPANY SAYS IT'S NOT
ACCURATE THAT LEAKED-INTERNAL
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES INSTAGRAM
IS TOXIC FOR TEEN GIRLS.
THE RESEARCH ACTUALLY DPEMEN
STRAIGHTED THAT MANY TEENS WE
HEARD FROM FEELS INSTAGRAM HELPS
THEM WHEN THEY ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THE HARD MOMENTS TEENAGERS
HAVE ALWAYS FACED.
THIS RESEARCH FOUND TEENS REPORT
HAVING BOTH POSITIVE AND
FWHEFW
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
I MEAN, I GUESS THE BROADER
POINT HERE IS THAT THEY ARE NOT
SAYING THERE IS NO BAD.
THEY ARE SAYING, THOUGH, THAT
THERE CAN BE GREAT GOOD.
>> WELL, MY RESPONSE WOULD BE
THAT -- IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THEY WERE LOOKING TO CREATE
AN INSTAGRAM FOR TEENS.
AND AFTER MY CLIENT HAD MADE HER
DISCLOSURES AND AFTER IT BECAME
PUBLIC, THAT THEY PUT A PAUSE ON
THAT EFFORT.
SO, THEY PRESUMABLY KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM.
WE ALL NOW KNOW THAT WHAT THEY
KNOW AND WHEN THEY KNEW IT.
AND NOW, IT'S UP TO CONGRESS AND
TO REGULATORS TO DETERMINE HOW
BEST TO HELP FACEBOOK FIX ITSELF
AND GO BACK TO ITS ROOTS.
>> SO, ANDREW, I WANT TO ASK YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW THE PREPARED
TESTIMONY HAS COME OUT TOMORROW
AND OBVIOUSLY SHE IS GOING TO
FACE A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
BUT MS. HAUGEN WILL SAY SHE
KNOWS FACEBOOK CAN, QUOTE,
DESTROY HER.
THAT'S THE WORD SHE USED.
SHE CAME FORWARD AT GREAT
PERSONAL RISK.
OBVIOUSLY, THESE ARE -- THESE
ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT THINGS TO
SAY.
IS SHE CONCERNED ABOUT HER
PHYSICAL SAFETY?
HAS SHE BEEN THREATENED.
>> >> I WOULD SAY THIS.
WE HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL MAKING A
WORLD OF A DIFFERENCE BECAUSE
SHE HAD THE COURAGE TO COME
FORWARD.
AND DISCLOSE WHAT SHE BELIEVED
TO BE WRONG TO FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REGULATORS.
AND IT'S HER AGAINST A
TRILLION-DOLLAR COMPANY.
SO TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, SHE IS
INTIMIDATED.
PERHAPS, A LITTLE BIT BY A